can i tell you a quick kanye store yeah
so when we were working on the dimita
joe album with janet um he came to the
studio it was a record plan i think we
were working at the village studio um at
that point
and i remember big john platt who's now
the head of sony publishing brought
kanye by and he said kanye's got some
stuff to play for you guys you might
want to listen and i said okay great so
he comes in
so the door closes and it's just me
kanye and janet sitting in the room
and kanye goes i'm thinking he's going
to pull out a tape or pull out something
in his computer and start playing
records right
he goes
y'all heard my new album and we were
like no we haven't heard it yet and he
said you want to hear it and we said
yeah he said cool i thought he was going
to put something on he just stands up
and starts wrapping the whole album
and after about 15 minutes of that big
john was standing it was in the lobby
and he wasn't hearing anything so he
popped his head in the room to see what
was going on yeah and he said how's it
going in here
oh he's doing the album
[Laughter]
so anyway that was my that was my kanye
story but that's when i knew
you know when you talk about genius yeah
he's a absolute genius